i definitely think that we we kind of we
uh you know we grow from each other i
think and there's a lot of like
kind of looking into it being like oh
wow like there's you know she still
writes a song every single day and i'm
like geez i gotta get on my game you
know so i think that it's like
it's a healthy sort of like supportive
um way we're growing together in that
way
so olivia's winning the write a song
every day challenge she is winning yes
i'm definitely losing that
hey everyone we've officially entered
the most wonderful time of the year
whether you've been naughty or nice
we've got the perfect gift
for you obviously it's a very
challenging time for people but i think
that
um it gave me a lot of time to like
really uh
hone in on songwriting and playing and
all those different things and so
i was actually able to finally record my
um
debut ep over the the course of the
quarantine which is again i know like a
lot of people
were very restricted so i'm very um you
know uh
it's just so wonderful that i had that
opportunity to do that but yeah i was
actually really grateful to have the
time to like
um just hone in on all that stuff but
yeah
yeah me too i actually recorded my debut
ep in quarantine too
um and uh yeah kind of to echo what
joshua said i think
both of us um are like really creative
and it was kind of nice to have some
time just
to sit with yourself and and your
thoughts and your ideas and
kind of have time to like mine that out
joshua actually challenged me
to write a song every day of quarantine
and like we both kind of
fell off a little bit but um definitely
like
challenging myself creatively was
something that happened a lot over
uh lockdown and i also learned how to
knit over lockdown which was fun
how did you keep in touch with your
fellow cast members was there a group
chat group
zooms hangs anything like that yeah we
actually had a weekly
uh group zoom tim federally the show
owner held it he was always just like
you know we just
checked in and i remember the first
couple weeks it was always like people
were just like
you know no one had any idea what was
going on but it was definitely nice to
kind of have that
weekly check and you know see
everybody's faces and see how everyone's
doing
the the group among us has that happened
yet no not yet
surprisingly i don't know why what i
want to do is i want to film a real life
among us at the sound stages and like
put a camera in every room or the
dressing rooms and like
figure that out but we're still working
on it so you are all kind of reunited
in salt lake city resuming filming how
has it been reuniting with your fellow
castmates we are still technically not
allowed to hug on set if we're ever like
closer than six feet apart somebody goes
up six feet apart so it's kind of
uh like a school dance party yeah i'm a
big hugger and i love everyone on set so
much so it's a little bit of a challenge
still but
um it was definitely so nice to see them
all again and and talk to them i think
they're kind of like our our second
family so uh
it was really hard being away from them
for so long how have you been able to
interact with the fans more on social
media keeping in touch with them i know
i'm trying to think was it youtube last
year that put passwords on each other's
phones and then forgot the passwords
yeah well i remembered my password and
joshua didn't remember
mine so mine is still locked but i don't
think his it's still locked
no block to the stay yup
oh my that's uh wow i feel terrible but
uh yeah we definitely had a thing where
we put locks on each other's instagram
so that
after 30 minutes we couldn't let go
because i would do it and like i would
just ignore the message because
you know i would just be like screw that
i'm still gonna go on but
that was gonna be held each other
accountable but i think like uh you know
there was a couple of times
that like each of us i think went live
during the the quarantine to kind of
like check in with everybody
see how everyone's doing but um yeah
it's definitely it's like it's weird
when like all real world activities stop
like you know award shows and interviews
and all that stuff where it all becomes
on social media it kind of is a it's a
it shows just how
social media has become real life in a
lot of ways and that's like where
all that is now is like social media and
people are doing concerts
you know for uh you know online it's
just a very it's a very weird
world so we definitely i think leaned
into you know connecting with people
more on social media
high school musical the musical the
holiday special
is coming out on disney plus on december
11th so what
what prompted this who's on one of the
cast zooms that we were talking about we
had like a weekly cast soon we were
locked down and
on one of them our showrunner tim
federly was like big announcement and we
were so excited and he's like
we're going to do like a holiday special
and each one of you is going to get a
holiday song that's gonna be amazing we
were so stoked
i think i was just personally so stoked
that we were like all gonna
be working together again uh because i
just missed that experience so much
um but it's fantastic we will do like
some christmas covers
hanukkah covers uh josh wrote an
original song
for the special which is amazing um and
i think my favorite part about it is you
kind of just get to learn more about
um like the actors as people and their
backstories and i remember
we watched it uh maybe like a couple
weeks ago for the first time and i
remember learning stuff about my cast
members that i had no idea
about before so i think people will kind
of
get to know us on a more human level
more which i'm excited for
i think the cool thing like again what
she was saying about the holiday special
is like you get to learn so much about
people and i think that because
this year we are um you know we
obviously the schedule's been pushed
around because of
all the time we've had to spend in
lockdown um this sort of nugget of
content that you're that everyone's
gonna get from our cast because
our season isn't coming out you know
directly
when it was supposed to because
everything got pushed back i think it'll
be a nice bridge but i'm really i really
think that the fans are gonna love it
and i think that
there's so much gold and like what is it
45 minutes i think it's like
it's the perfect jam-packed piece of
gold that i think that they're all gonna
love
olivia you sing a joni mitchell classic
river in the special
does that song hold any like a special
meaning to you
how did that choice come about yeah um
so tim fetterly our showrunner and our
producer uh
knows that i'm a big songwriter and i
love female singer songwriters like
that's my jam
and so when this opportunity came about
he's like okay like the best
female singer songwriter christmas song
is river which is like the sad christmas
song and i love
ballads and i love sad songs and so he's
like this is perfect for olivia
and i actually had only heard it
previously
on the politician uh ben platt sings it
in the politician and i thought it was
like a politician
original song so i was like oh wait this
is like amazing and this is joni
mitchell and she's the greatest and i
actually like
uh dove into her discography after like
learning about this song
um but yeah i i'm just feel really
grateful that i uh that i got to do it
and i think it turned out really well
so yeah josh you perform a song that you
wrote
for for season two is it the perfect
yeah
yes what can you tell us about it
yeah i mean the perfect gift is uh you
know it sort of stems from
a ricky not being able to like afford a
gift and so
as the second best thing he writes a
song but the
ultimate gift is you know the the other
person so i think that
that's kind of the key thing of the song
is uh i mean the main line at the end is
this song is the second best that i
could do when the perfect gift is you
and so it's kind of being like you know
this christmas like all i really want is
you
so this is the best i can give you is
the song um and so that's kind of
how that came about um and i can't give
away too much of the context within the
episode but
yeah that's that's the gist of the song
you also do a fun duet with matt
burnette that was
so wonderful little st so what was it
like getting to sing
uh with matt and do you would you like
to see more uh ricky ej duets in the
next season
i would love to see that yes matt and i
don't have too many scenes together it's
so funny we're either fighting or we're
glancing at each other from across the
room so
the fact that we were able to just be
buddies and do this song was a dream and
we got to shoot at the bachelor house
which was super fun
uh swimming the bachelor pool uh but
yeah it was it was definitely a blast we
were just
screwing around the whole day and just
having a good time so
yeah are you a bachelor fan did you like
reenact any bachelor moments
yeah no i wish we should have gotten a
limo but no i'm actually i
i've never really seen too much of the
bachelor i've seen like
pieces here and there but um yeah i'm
still cool
that's funny i know you're you're
gearing up for season two can you give
us a little glimpse of what we can
expect in the new season
without giving too much away i think
there are like amazing dance numbers
new amazing songs um obviously it was
announced that we're doing beauty and
the beast and that has been so much fun
um i think my favorite thing about
season two and um
like this series in general is that
there are like
no side characters and i think in season
two that's just
kind of um an extension of that
principle i think people that
we kind of just touched on in season two
will really get to
know really deeply and well so uh i'm
excited for that and i'm excited for
the audience to kind of know characters
a little bit more
um there's a bunch of drama you never
really know what's coming
so yeah so much good stuff
how are ricky and nene doing as a couple
that's a really great question uh
there's lots of challenges
there's lots of challenges lots of stuff
to figure out uh
that's an award on my apologies for that
um so you'll just have to uh
you'll just have to tune in we really
can't say anything but lots twists and
turns lots of exciting stuff
uh yeah it's it's good is there a
character that you
would like to do more scenes with maybe
you didn't get enough with them last
season
i'm i mean anytime i can act with sophia
wiley it's like a
magical like she she is one of those
people that like
makes you a better actor when you're
with her it's like so she's so wonderful
but also like i said earlier like
i don't know ricky and ej there's
there's got to be some more there right
like
i would love to see more of them too
together on on camera
yeah yeah there are definitely um some
cast members who haven't like really had
like one-on-one scenes with i don't
think i've had a one-on-one team with
frankie or joe or any of them and i
think that would be really fun because i
love them as people and also as actors
i love that so we we touched on your
music a little bit but i want to circle
back because you both wrote songs for
the new season yes
amazing so how would you say you've both
grown personally as musicians since the
start of the series
oh god immensely immensely
um i think about this all the time and i
think
a big reason that i grew so much is
because i met joshua who is obviously
this
amazing musician singer-songwriter and i
think
before that i had never really met
anyone that was kind of interested in
the same things that i was interested in
that was like my age
and uh that was really inspiring and i
think he really pushes me to do better
um so there's that aspect of it but
obviously getting to write
for the show is such an amazing
opportunity and getting to write
something that you know will be like
heard by people
is obviously kind of a lot of pressure
but
i think made me better as a songwriter
totally and writing to prompt is
something that i'm really trying to get
used to like being like okay this is
what i have to write about and this is
all the points that i have to touch on
that's something that i never really did
before i kind of just
like wrote what i was feeling and so
it's kind of nice to be able to
write something from a more structured
approach but uh yeah
immensely grateful for everything that
the show has taught me it's it's really
infinite
yeah i mean i just i agree
wholeheartedly with everything uh that
she said i think
in the beginning like it is very
daunting when you you know you get that
task of like
we need you to write this song like she
said but i think that like this time
around when when tim gave me the call
and he was like okay even when you wrote
this song blah blah
i was more like okay let's like let's do
this like i just had more like a
um i was i was just more like all right
let's gotta face this head on but i
think
one of the things that i've i've really
learned from olivia is
the um the storytelling aspect of
songwriting and i think that i
you know i'm more of like a this is how
i feel in this moment and she really
does a job of like
telling a story and putting you in that
time and place and i think that
that's been super um inspiring to me and
has definitely influenced
my music but i definitely think that we
we kind of we
uh you know we grow from each other i
think and there's a lot of like
kind of looking each other like oh wow
like there's you know she still writes a
song every single day and i'm like geez
i gotta get on my game you know so i
think that it's like
it's a healthy sort of like supportive
um way we're growing together in that
way
so olivia's winning the write a song
every day challenge she is winning yes
i'm definitely losing that
i don't know about every day i
definitely sit at my piano and puts
around every day
over like lockdown i wrote one every day
for like maybe three four months
which was i was so proud of myself for
but um obviously they're
most of them were absolutely awful but
you know it's the thought that counts at
the practice
who are your biggest uh inspirations in
the industry olivia
oh um taylor swift i'm the biggest
swiftie in the whole world
i think she is the most genius
songwriter um she just
like works so hard and is such a
storyteller and uses such specificity
and i'm just obsessed with her
um i love lord too i'm a big lord person
um i love like halsey and just like
female singer songwriters who really
aren't afraid to say what's on their
mind uh yeah
josh how about you um i think uh
like ed sheeran is such an inspiration
to me because he's able to play seventy
thousand seat stadiums with just his
guitar and loot pedal i think that just
shows that he really is like he was a
street performer like he really just
he he just did the grind and he he he
did great and then obviously
her style is a huge inspiration because
he's not only like so good at the music
but also like he's a fashion icon and i
think that he's
he's not afraid to take risks and be
super bold and that's super inspiring to
me
john mayer is also an excellent um
inspiration for me i love sara bareilles
like norah jones all those people
um yeah i mean i could go on and on but
songwriters really
so you you recorded an ep in quarantine
what's the update it is not out here no
it is coming i have not i've not given
any official
dates yet but soon very soon didn't mark
my word jam
olivia congratulations on all i want
being certified gold
hey yo has it sunk in yet what does this
accomplishment mean to you
oh yeah i mean it's just crazy i
i just feel so lucky that i got to write
this song for a show that means so much
to me and that i love so much and
the fact that people like listened to it
and liked it it's just icing on the cake
um i think it's so cool i uh i sometimes
like go on tick-tock and like
look at people making uh videos for the
song it's like people like
make tick tocks which is just so cool
but um like recently i was like looking
at the comments
um of a video that was to the song and
people were like talking about
uh what the song meant to them and like
how it helped them get through like
certain
heartbreaks and like sad times in their
life and like reading it was like
made me feel like so seen that all of
these people were going through
experiences that i was going through
and there was just like nothing like
that there was just nothing like that
connection and
um yeah i just feel so so grateful that
they let me do this and that
people liked it the way that they did so
uh last season you both co-wrote just
for a moment is there
another you talk about how you guys are
kind of you kind of push each other to
do better
are we gonna see more collaborations
between you guys maybe inside or outside
of the show yeah um
we didn't get a chance to write anything
together for this season but uh
maybe next season who knows but yeah
riding with josh was a pleasure so
yeah maybe in the future we'll do
something like that we'll see
so a lot of fans have discovered this
series as part of their kind of
quarantine binges
what has it meant to you both to be able
to like bring a little bit of joy to
people
during this difficult time
yeah i mean i just think about all the
comfort shows that i had like growing up
and
it's it's so insane to me for people to
be like this is my comfort show like
this show
is like my escape and like because the
world is so scary right now and people
are
stuck in their houses and you know i'm
sure
it's just like with all the challenges
going on the idea that people for what i
don't know is it
six hours total i think is the first
season like for people to escape for
even that amount of time and to give
them that joy is
the most fulfilling thing and um
something i'm honored to be a part of
and excited to bring them
more of that comfort uh comfort tv
in uh in just a short amount of time
right
and like streaming is really the only
option for entertainment these days so
um you know it's it's kind of cool that
we get to be in people's households when
they're obviously
stuck indoors um but i think one of my
favorite things about the show
is that uh it really focuses in on like
finding your tribe and like feeling
accepted and feeling like you belong and
i think that's something that
we all stay it's at least i do um
so i'm really glad that we're kind of
driving that message home i hope people
feel
uh included in love are we getting any
sneak peek of season two in the holiday
special
i'm glad you asked yes you are well one
there's my song a perfect gift we'll be
uh i'll be performing that in the
holiday special and then also there is a
clip
from season two um that i am so excited
about it it was the most fun
thing to film ever i would i watched
every single take of it i was like this
is incredible so i'm just so excited
to get that little little taste of
season two buckle up wildcats
it's about to get real
you